Have you
ever watched one of those viral videos
where a baby hears their parents
for the first time
after getting a cochlear implant
and thought, "Aw, so adorable!"
Well, what if I told you that the history
leading up to
that moment isn't quite so cute?
In videos like these, doctors place
an electronic device near a Deaf person's
ear that sends auditory
signals to the brain similar to hearing.
The hope behind these implants
is that they'll allow the Deaf person
to participate
fully in the mainstream hearing world.
But many Deaf advocates
say that this process is trying to fix
something that just isn't broken.
Instead,
they want us to recognize that Deaf people
already have a rich linguistic culture
and community of sign language users
with just as much validity
as any other language.
And that signing needs less attempts
at correction and more of our attention.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky, and this is Otherwords.
Otherwords.
I interviewed Roberta Cordano,
president of Gallaudet University,
to discuss what many of us misunderstand
about sign language.
I would say the biggest misperception
is the power
and importance of American Sign Language
or sign language in general.
Just visual learning. Visual language.
I think too many people,
especially in health care,
health care professionals,
really completely misunderstand
how important visual language is for brain
development,
how important and equivalent
ASL is to English.
When we try to describe what language is,
a lot of people think about the shapes
we make with our mouths when we speak
or the sounds we hear
or even the words we read.
But gestures and facial expressions
are also parts of language.
Every human being,
wherever you are in the world,
already has about 200 gestures
that are innate to them as human beings.
The brain already knows how to produce
these gestures.
But the problem is instead that we have
had gesturing scolded out of us.
I mean, think about it, right?
If you think about someone pointing?
You're always told not to point!
That it's not polite. Right?
But imagine how efficient it is:
if I point in one direction.
You look to where I pointed.
I don't have to say a single word.
Sign languages are produced with hand
movements, head
movements and facial expressions
rather than sounds.
They have all the same structural
characteristics that spoken languages do.
They have complex vocabulary,
including regional variations and slang
and grammatical rules,
where things like the speed,
direction and position of a sign
can change its meaning.
And there's just as much vibrance and
variety in sign languages as spoken ones.
There are more than 150 different
sign languages used around the world
that are distinct from each other and
the spoken languages in the same places.
The only people in the world
who are still creating language--not just words, but actual languages--
The only people who are still creating
languages in the world are Deaf people.
Spoken languages have been static
for the last 500 years.
As I understand it,
the last couple of hundred years, there's
no new spoken
languages being developed anywhere.
But that's not true for sign language.
You know, where
there are Deaf people coming together,
they create new sign languages
to communicate.
I mean, that's incredible.
Sign language seems pretty cool, right?
So why don't more of us sign?
That's where we get into
some pretty painful history.
Until the early 1800s,
most Deaf people born in the U.S.
didn't have access to education
that could meet their needs.
But in 1816, a collaboration
between French educators and American
advocates raised a bunch of money
and established a school for the Deaf,
where students could learn and communicate
using signs instead of speech.
Finally, these students had access
to education, but even more importantly,
to a Deaf community
where they could sign with each other.
The French sign language
these teachers brought started to combine with
the signs that students made up at home
or in their own communities
to create American Sign Language or ASL.
But not everybody liked
this new model of education.
Some academic hotshots
like Alexander Graham Bell--
Yes, that Alexander Graham Bell--
argued that Deaf people,
including his own Deaf mother and wife,
should try to integrate into mainstream
speaking culture as best they could.
So in 1880, Bell and 164 other educators--
(only one of them Deaf)
met at a conference to create recommendations
for Deaf education in the U.S.
and Europe.
They believed that sign language
was a lesser imitation of spoken language
and that Deaf kids
shouldn't be taught to sign in schools.
Instead,
they created a system called Oralism,
where Deaf children were expected to hear
by lip reading
and speak by imitating the mouth
shapes of hearing people.
That conference was catastrophic
for the Deaf community.
It ended most sign language
instruction in schools until the 1960s.
That's almost 100 years where many Deaf
people had little to no access
to sign language education, or the ability
to form communities with fellow signers.
And it was only in 2013
that there was an apology
issued to the Deaf community
for the Milan Conference,
the declaration that spoke to banning
sign language back in the 1880s.
That apology to the Deaf community
that came in 2013 was one
that my mother was still alive to see,
and my mother suffered because of that
decree during that period of time.
And my mother said, you know,
I finally have lived to see this apology
that happened in her lifetime,
and it meant a lot to her.
The problem is,
you can't just treat someone like they're
not Deaf and expect them to blend in.
Even the most skilled lip readers report
that they can only pick up
about a third of conversations.
So that means that most Deaf
people denied access to sign
language are being denied access
to language, period.
And that can have some serious
consequences for brain development.
The most important time
to expose someone to language, for them
to develop fluency, and for their brain
to be developed,
you know, the language
to be actually mapped to the language
mapping center of the brain is between
the ages of birth and five.
So we know that any human being
who wants to acquire a language, between
that window is the best opportunity
for them to be able to map that language
to the right area of the brain.
Research has shown
that children who acquire language late,
whether signed or spoken,
are less likely to use the important
language centers of the brain.
Instead, they process language
in the visual or memory centers,
a less efficient process that can still
allow for a large vocabulary
but might inhibit a natural grasp
of the language's grammar.
Every child who is Deaf or hard of hearing
is at high risk
of experiencing language
delay, language deprivation.
And it’s not because the child's
brain has a limited capacity,
but rather it's more about the fact
that they've not been able to have access
to information in a stress-free environment
where they can just learn freely.
When I was younger,
I was the only Deaf person in the class
and I had to sit there
and every minute of that class,
I had to watch to make sure I understood
what was being said by the instructor.
Then I had to figure out
what was the meaning of the message
that was being shared in spoken language.
And then I had to think about,
Well, what is it that I just learned?
And then I have to be ready to be called
on by the teacher at any point in time.
So I was doing four separate functions
every minute of every single day,
all day long,
and that's absolutely exhausting.
Even newer technology
like hearing aids or cochlear implants
don't work for all
or even most Deaf people.
A majority of cochlear implant recipients
still cannot pick up
spoken language at a level comparable
to a hearing person.
Of course, we know
there are many examples of where people
who are raised, what we call orally,
meaning that they have hearing aids
or cochlear implants.
There are many Deaf
and hard of hearing people
who are very successful going that route
and they thrive in their careers.
I mean, in no way am I criticizing
that approach and that lifestyle.
I think that's just wonderful.
And again,
I'm not blaming the doctors here
because we also realize that as well
that in their doctor kit
that they bring to the table,
they're not given anything that speaks to
a prescription for ASL. Right?
That's not in their tool kit.
Right. Insurances
pay for cochlear implants.
They pay for hearing aids, but they sure
don't pay for language support.
What I'm trying to do is to get people
to realize that there's a false choice
that we're setting up here,
that you have to choose one way
of communicating
or the other. Both are needed.
Both are beneficial.
So why not do both?
Why not give the child everything
to that child's disposal, to have to use
whatever they need and see whatever
best suits them and what they pick up.
Depriving a Deaf child of sign language
in hopes they'll learn
spoken language puts them at a high risk
for having difficulty
with any language later in life.
But the reverse is also true.
Learning to sign from birth,
whether alone or alongside
spoken language,
has some major cognitive benefits.
If you saw our video on bilingualism,
you'll remember that bilingual kids
grow up with cognitive advantages
in memory and attention.
The same holds true for kids
who learn both ASL and English,
but because sign language uses
additional areas of the brain,
people who speak and sign get a boost
in visual and spatial processes too,
like giving directions
or remembering faces.
And that's true for people who are hearing
or Deaf.
In fact, research will show that learning
sign language for all babies,
Deaf and hearing, will impact
their brain in such a way
that it will allow for further development
of abstract thinking.
Pattern recognition is enhanced.
There's loads of benefits that visual
language and visual learning provide.
It allows your brain to thrive in
different ways that otherwise it couldn't.
I mean, it's just amazing what can happen
when you get exposed to a spoken language
and a visual language.
And that's why I encourage having both.
So even though for hundreds of years,
society
thought that Deaf people
would miss out on language and culture
if they learned to sign,
this whole time, it's non signers
who've been missing out
on an entire dimension of language
and on a vibrant community
of Deaf people who use it.
So what I recognize is,
is that we have been so busy
trying to fix Deaf babies or Deaf
hard of hearing babies
by putting technologies on them
and trying to fix them
so that they'll be hearing
and be able to access spoken language
that we've completely missed out
on what those Deaf babies have
to offer the entire world:
a lifetime experience of hearing loss.
And I think we've really got it wrong.
The babies are our teachers
in this process.
They are teaching us how to live
with the beauty of a visual language,
how to live in a world full of visual
images and visual communication.
You know, it's just a way of being
that is so beneficial to everyone,
if you learn sign language
and use sign language.
The more of us that join
the signing community,
the more we can experience broader
and more complex ways of thinking
and more inclusive ways
of communicating with each other.
Before you go!
We're looking for your feedback.
Each year, PBS Digital Studio conducts an audience survey.
It helps us understand what you like and what you want to see more of.
You also get to help PBS pick new shows.
It only takes a few minutes, but your feedback is extremely valuable to us.
There's a link in the description. Thanks in advance!